we're at buddy Electric tattoo and I'm
getting my very first tattoo I'm afraid
of needles because last year I got a
piercing and the piercing got stuck
under my skin I know nothing about
getting tattoos and I'm so scared but
blood is gonna go everywhere and it's
gonna be like sweetie Tom this is like a
sweetie Taj here did you notice that
today I'm getting the pyramid since I'm
Egyptian I think I need to connect to
that part of me and I'm getting you're
full of wonder right under it my writing
and filmmaking means a lot to me and so
I have when the world is listening what
will you say I want to get a really
simple guitar tattoo right over here
there in my life and especially there my
childhood it was something that really
helped me deal with a lot of things in
my life I hope I don't regret it I hope
this is a great idea I just don't want
blood to go everywhere is that what's
gonna happen I don't know what's
happening right now yeah I have no idea
what's going on so you're not just
drilling into my skin well I am just
drilling into your skin oh I'm just
gonna lie to my mom as long as I can
[Music]
I feel like the closer to the movie cos
it hurts I was just sitting there and I
was just pondering liar you know when
you have like sharp pencil and just
someone just snapping you it kind of
feels like someone who's like having
into my skin oh that hurts
are we done I held my breath for 40
minutes oh yeah I feel relieved that
it's done and there weren't any
earthquakes I feel like a new person I
can't believe I just did this look
awesome I love it look I love this
I'm really glad I did it because the
outcome is so beautiful it definitely
feels like someone's ripping off your
skin but at the end I'm proud that I had
this experience I don't think the fear
of needles would go away I think it's
just the way you think of needles a week
or so from now I'll probably forget that
it hurt and I'll be like yeah
tattoos needles great let me go get a
flu shot I think I would get another
tattoo honestly I feel much stronger
seeing it happening made me feel like oh
I couldn't do anything people say look
at once you get one you get addicted to
it nah I hope my mom doesn't fill me